What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. Tonight is
actually part two of another video. If
you guys did not see the video called
the cosmic week, you got to check it
out. It was so interesting, so eye
opening to realize that Jesus is coming
soon that I don't even think we have
five more years. That's just my personal
opinion by looking at the signs of the
times, by reading through scriptures and
different things like that. But I
believe that we are living in the end.
All the signs are saying so. And we did
that show with my friend Wendy here and
we had a lot of attacks during that show
and the live stream just dropped off
before we could finish it. So, we wanted
to invite you back to kind of finish
that idea up and actually add some more
to the conversation. So, thank you for
coming back on.
>> Yeah, Mikey, thanks for having me. It
was a crazy night for sure and I'm glad
that we can come back and look at this
again.
>> Me, too. And a lot of the comments were
saying like, "Oh, it cut off. It left me
hanging." Like, "Is there going to be a
part two?" And so I asked you and I
said, "Should we come back and do it?"
Cuz you said you only had like a few
more slides, but you actually have a
bigger idea to present here about the
biblical feast. You know, a lot of
people look at them. Some people really
are into them. Some people are like,
"Ah, that's the old covenant. It's
gone." But I do think that they served a
purpose. At least when they were
created, God made them for a reason. I
don't think that God ever said, "Hey, I
want you to do this thing just because I
said so." Um, he's very detailoriented
and um, we were even looking at some
some like Bible codes and things like
that. I think the Bible is full of codes
and symbols. And when you look at
prophecy, it's like a beast is a kingdom
and a the woman is the church and all
these things. And I think you see a lot
of that in the feast. There's these
symbols of painting the blood on the
doorpost so that you would be passed
over. Well, that was actually a symbol
pointing to Christ. Even the the lamb
sacrifice, there was no power in the
blood of a lamb at all. But it was a
symbol pointing to Christ. So all the
all the feast, all the um what do you
call them? The rituals or whatever, they
were actually
showing people the gospel because they
were living in a time before the Messiah
came and they knew prophetically that a
Messiah was going to come and redeem
them of their sins. But they had these
uh holy days that would help them to
remember, help them to understand what
was going to come in the future. And now
we're living in a time where that was
the past and we can look at that in the
past. We don't have to sacrifice a lamb.
The veil is torn from top to bottom. Um
that's not a a necessary thing. But I do
believe that there is some importance in
the feasts uh and the symbolism and
you're going to talk about some of that
because it actually could point to the
return of Christ which I think is really
interesting.
>> Yeah, 100%. I love what you said like
there's a lot that we can learn still
and some people are almost afraid to
touch the feast because they don't want
to be labeled the feast keeper
>> actually there are quite a few people
that have been like uninvited from
church
>> wow
>> and kind of like blacklisted because
they've been feastepers and like
personally I'm not a feasteper but my
husband and I we really just started
studying this and what you see in here
the symbology is amazing and yeah if
like if God's people had lost the feasts
they wouldn't have recognized Jesus when
he came. They would have lost it
completely.
>> So, it's super important for them. But I
also think there's a lot for us here,
too.
>> And the last time we spoke, it was
crazy. I actually spoke about the
Passover and then it skipped a ton of
the slides. So, we're going to go
through some of it again.
>> This is where we left off. So, with the
Passover, I'm just going to review
quickly. The important thing to learn
from this is that Jesus died
specifically on the 14th of Nissan,
which was the preparation day before the
high Sabbath. Like literally the exact
time frame that the lambs were being
slain, which is really beautiful.
>> So after the Passover,
oh, I wanted to include this because
literally my husband and I were just
studying about the feasts. And I'll be
honest, when we talk to Christian about
the feasts, different Christians about
the feasts, we get a lot of backlash.
And I'm like, we're just we're just
studying, you know, like I'm not going
to close my ears and eyes to anything in
the Bible. I I think God has something
for all of us through the whole Bible.
>> And so when we were studying, we looked
at 1 Corinthians 5'8 and it says, "For
indeed Christ our Passover was
sacrificed for us. Let us therefore,
sorry, therefore let us keep the feasts,
not with old leavenven, nor with the
leavenven of malice and wickedness, but
with the unleavened bread of sincerity
and truth.
>> Amen.
>> And now my question to my husband, like
we were literally talking about this.
I'm like, wait,
>> so many people say that after Jesus, the
feasts were fulfilled, so there's no
need for them. And they were like, yeah,
okay, so maybe the Jewish people kept
keeping the feasts, but that was one of
the things that they told the new
converts, like, you don't have to keep
the feasts. you don't have to keep the
Sabbath, you don't have to do all these
things. But then why we started
questioning like why was Paul speaking
to former Gentiles about keeping a
feast? Like he literally could have said
don't have the sin of malice and
wickedness, but he used this in the
symbology of the unleavened bread. But
literally, he could have been like, "You
don't need to keep the feasts, but let's
look at it this way." But he literally
says, "Let us keep the feast."
So, it's interesting. It just makes me
think like I really don't know what to
say about that other than there's more
in the feast that we need to be looking
at.
>> We know that God is not a respector of
persons. There's neither Jew nor Greek.
We're all one in Christ Jesus. Like, are
we going to ignore
>> that? I don't I don't believe that there
is something that, oh, if you were born
of this bloodline, you have to live life
this way because you're a Jew. Like, I
don't believe that at all. They're under
the same They're in the same situation
we are. Jesus Christ is the way, the
truth, and the life. And if you reject
him, like a lot of Jewish people do
today, you will not enter the kingdom.
There's no one comes to the father but
by me. And yet their whole religion is
to reject Jesus Christ. And so there's a
lot of people that think they're God's
chosen people and I stand with Israel
and all these things. That's like a
whole different thing I don't want to
get into. But I just don't believe that
Jews are supposed to do something
different than any other Christian. We
are all one. There's we're all called to
do the same thing to be a believer and
to enter the kingdom. And that's to
believe in Jesus Christ and
>> follow his commandments.
>> Absolutely. And one of the things that
kind of helped me think through this was
when Jesus talked about Christians and
Gentiles being added in, he didn't say
like, "Let's cut down the tree." Right?
He's like, "I'm not I'm going to cut
down the Jewish tree and I'm going to
plant a new seed and these will be my
children." Instead, he said,
>> "The Gentiles will now be grafted in."
>> Amen.
>> So, we are grafted into the tree that
was, you know, spiritual Israel,
spiritual Judaism. But now, it says
we're all Jews spiritually. We are the
seed of Abraham spiritually. So, yeah, I
think it's really important for us to
look at these things. So, here's where
it gets great because we know that Jesus
died right at Passover at the time of
the Passover lambs. Well, right over
Passover, technically Passover is like
the first day of the feast of unleavened
bread, but they call it Passover because
of the Passover um Egypt of Egypt. And
so, when we look at the unleavened
bread, symbolically, it's about the
condition of the heart and the life
after redemption. And this is actually
something that's pretty cool and I think
it's kind of lost on us today. But the
children were supposed to help in this.
And so what the Israelites did was for
the feast of unleaven bread before it
began, they had to search their entire
house for every crumb, every tiny trace
of leaven that was in their house. And
they made bread daily. So like there was
probably yeast everywhere. And they were
out for like a day like sweeping. And
all the children were had to help and
like searching everywhere for this
leaven. Uh but what that taught them was
self-examination because they knew that
levan stood for sin. And like Jesus even
says that at one point like beware of
the leavenven of the Pharisees.
>> Yeah.
>> And it said that
>> they were all like wait do they have bad
bread or something? Is it cuz we eat
their bread? He's like no it's a sin.
Come on guys.
>> Yeah.
>> So yeah it's supposed to teach us though
um not to tolerate small sin because
just like leaven puffs up and gets
bigger with time. Sin does the same
thing. When we accept a little bit of
sin in our lives, it always snowballs.
Like it always compiles and grows bigger
and bigger.
>> Yeah, for sure. And so I think this is a
really great like object lesson for
kids. Um I've never done it with my
kids, but we probably will do it in the
future just because I love the symbology
of it.
>> And then again, it teaches urgency as
they were leaving Egypt in haste. um we
are called to that immediate obedience
when God calls us and convicts us. You
know, today is the day of salvation. So,
we don't want to put that off.
>> And then this is the beautiful symbology
of this feast. It says the bread of life
was placed in the tomb. During the feast
that celebrates bread without
corruption. So like the picture here,
Jesus is put in the tomb. And unleavened
bread is obviously the bread that's made
without leaven or without sin. So it
just perfectly points to Jesus.
>> Oh, that is amazing.
>> Yeah. And then first fruits, I didn't
know this before studying, but literally
the feast of first fruits, it's very
specific. It occurs um so the
resurrection specifically occurs on
first fruits. And when we look at
Leviticus 23:10 and 11, it says, "When
you come into the land, you shall bring
a sheath of the first fruits." And it's
on the day after the Sabbath during the
feast of unleavened bread. So the
biblical calendar can fall on any day of
the week. It's not, you know, it's not
like the Gregorian calendar where Easter
or whatever is always on the third
Sunday or I don't know what I don't know
how that works out to be honest. But
>> the biblical calendar moves around a
lot. And so all we know is that first
fruits is the um the day after the
Sabbath when you're looking at the the
feast of unleven bread. And so we see in
first Corinthians 15:20 that Christ has
been raised from the dead and they call
him the first fruits of those who had
fallen asleep. And like he was literally
raised from the dead on the first
fruits. And that is why all this
scripture was written afterwards by Paul
that he was the first fruits because
they were very aware of what feast day
it was. And so I love the way that this
is put, but it's not redemptive
coincidence. Like God does nothing by
accident. This is redemptive
choreography. Like these are the steps
that he put in place long before it
happened. Again, like Jesus had no
control over when he was crucified. He
had no control over when he was
resurrected. All that was up to the
father. But this is what the father did.
He worked according to the feast
timeline
>> to wake up the Jewish people.
>> And so the big picture here is that
Passover means redemption by blood,
right? The blood of the lamb covers our
sins. And then unleavened bread after we
receive that um redemption by Jesus,
then we have the ability to remove the
sin. Because before that, like we can
try to be good, but we're going to fail
time and time again.
>> Yeah. until we come to Jesus, until we
ask for the Holy Spirit, it's just
impossible. We can't do it in our own
strength. And so the unleavened bread
shows the removal of sin and the
possibility of that removal. And then
first fruits where Jesus is raised to
life, that's where new life begins. And
so it's just this beautiful picture of
salvation for us through these feasts.
I'll keep moving. So this is where it
gets interesting too because a lot of
people will say okay God clearly used
the calendar. He clearly used the feasts
for Jesus's death and his resurrection.
We see that Yasher. But then they'll say
after that the calendar God's calendar
and the feasts were put to death at
Jesus after Jesus fulfilled them. We no
longer need to study or keep them in any
way. But what we see in the future is
that literally the feast of weeks is
counted after Passover begins. So it's
50 days or seven sevens. So like seven
weeks after um Passover. Pentecost
literally means 50. So that's where the
word Pentecost come from comes from. But
the crazy thing about this is the Jewish
people were told God's disciples, God's
Jesus's disciples, they were told to tar
in Jerusalem. And he was telling them,
"The Holy Spirit's going to come to you,
but wait in Jerusalem." And they waited
there and waited. And it says that the
uh the Holy Spirit was given to them in
Acts 2. But it was on a day that they
were up in the upper room and they were
together fasting and praying. And when
you look at this, this was actually the
feast of weeks because that involves a
lot of um fasting. And so they were
together celebrating this feast together
on this day. And that is when the Holy
Spirit came down. And what's great about
this is it's a harvest feast and it's um
the feast of weeks is at the beginning
of the harvest season. And so this
completely mimics what God was doing in
the Bible in Acts 2. The Holy Spirit was
given and literally thousands came to
the truth in one day, which compared to
what they were doing before, like this
was huge.
>> And so this shows us that God's harvest
is people, not produce. Obviously, he
doesn't really care about the food.
>> But it also shows us some other really
great things. One is that we need the
spirit. We have to wait for that Holy
Spirit before we can do anything
worthwhile for the kingdom. And the
other thing is there's often a gap
between when God gives us a promise and
when he fulfills it. And that waiting
season is really important. Like they
waited 50 days.
>> And if you think about like after Jesus
was resurrected, that's a long time to
wait. you know, they're like, "All
right, Jesus is resurrected. Like, our
hope isn't shattered. Let's get to
work." And then God's like, "Okay, wait
50 days." That's a long time.
>> They be like, "Why? Like, why all the
waiting?"
>> But in my mind, like, it doesn't make
sense. You would think that they would
they'd want to get to work right away.
And they were already in Jerusalem. And
he told them like, "Don't leave
Jerusalem. Wait here."
>> But what this shows me is like God was
waiting for Pentecost.
>> He was waiting for this feast to fulfill
this. So it's pretty amazing.
>> But this is a time when we look at this,
it shows that personal salvation, which
is what we see through Passover, turns
into public mission. And so the
disciples were then equipped to go out
and instead of like the whole time that
Jesus was with him. I mean they were
doing things for the Lord. They were
preparing cities and towns and going two
by two and you know preparing them for
the gospel. But really what was
happening the most was God was Jesus was
comp preparing them like their hearts
>> the work that Jesus needed to do in them
was being done. And it wasn't until
after his crucifixion that a lot of them
really started understanding the truth
of what Jesus was saying.
>> Wow. Yeah. When I hear the word
Pentecost, I my mind automatically goes
to the picture you're seeing where the
flame is on the
>> disciples heads and stuff, but it was
actually a feast, right?
>> Yeah. It's called the feast of weeks.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. It's amazing when you actually
research that the fact that Pentecost
means 50. So that's why they started
calling it uh like when they say
Pentecost is the day that the the flame
of fire came down on them. But that's
just another name for the feast of
weeks.
>> Wow.
>> Which I didn't know before studying
this.
>> Yeah, I didn't either till now.
>> Okay. Yeah, it's awesome. And so this is
a scripture from Desire of Ages and it's
talking about um just as Christ arose
from the dead as the first fruits of
those that slept. So she's acknowledging
here that yes, he was the first fruits
and she she speaks a lot about how the
feasts are good for studying but that
the um the ceremony the cere ceremonial
aspects of the feasts are no longer what
we are bound to.
>> And I agree with that because I mean
like we said before in part one when
Jesus was crucified that veil was ripped
in half
>> and because of that we no longer have to
have that separation from God. We don't
we no longer have to do the ceremonial
things of the um the temple, right, and
the sanctuary. But there's still a lot
we can learn from the sanctuary. It's
not like we just going to turn a blind
eye and be like, "Okay, that was for
them. I don't need to know anything
about it." Like, we still need to learn
these things to figure out a bigger
picture of salvation.
>> This is so interesting though. So desire
of ages it says in like manner the types
which relate to the second advent must
be fulfilled at the time pointed out in
the symbolic service.
And so this is really huge. Like she's
saying the ceremonial aspects are no
longer necessary but she points out that
the symbolic aspects of the feasts are
very much still relevant. And here she
says like literally
>> it's going to be fulfilled at the time
pointed out like Christ's return is
going to be be fulfilled at the time
pointed out in the symbolic service.
>> H
>> so like that's kind of mind-blowing if
we want to know more about
>> the second advent of Christ like we have
to understand these feasts otherwise
it's just gonna I mean there's going to
be so much that's just going to be lost
on us
>> right?
>> So yeah I read that and I was just like
whoa. Okay. Okay. I wonder if people are
getting like blast blacklisted from
churches and and kicked out.
>> That's crazy.
>> Like to me it's almost like proof, you
know? It's like God says if if the world
loves you
>> Yep.
>> then it's because you don't properly
love me.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's like okay, my my thinking is
like if people are getting pushed to the
side by any popular faith, I don't care
what faith it is. In my mind, it's like,
okay, they're doing something right
because the enemy always tries to
silence the truth.
>> Well, I just think it's interesting,
too, that Satan counterfeits everything
of God. And so, we have all these pagan
holy days that we keep, you know, that
the government shuts down and, you know,
stores shut down. No, you can't go to
Walmart on Christmas time or whatever.
And so, there's all these pagan holidays
that we've been tricked into keeping.
And when you wake up to like, I'm not
going to do this anymore because it's
pagan. Well, now there's an empty void.
Like God created certain days for us to
keep
>> um that were very special and symbolic
and all these things and pointed to him.
They really pointed to him. Not like we
try to say Christmas and Easter point to
Christ and somehow they don't. That was
just, you know, that's um the Bible
actually warns
>> God says, I think it's in Jeremiah, but
God says, "Don't look at how the
heathens worship their gods and say we
will do likewise." That we're going to
worship God the same way they do. And he
says, "I hate what they do."
>> Like, don't do that. Like, don't look
and say, "Oh, you know what? They have a
Christmas tree. We're going to bring a
tree in our house and we're going to say
it's for Jesus or whatever." He says,
"Don't do that." Specifically, very,
very specific. And um
>> so when when we get those things out of
our life, it seems like we would replace
them with
the the truth instead of the
counterfeit. And the truth would be
these things where we get together and
we look at, you know, what Passover was
about. Like let's read the story. Let's
let's go into the Bible and see what it
was like when they put the blood over
the doorpost and and all the firstborns
were being killed by the angel of death
except for those that were under the
blood that represented Jesus. You know,
I just
>> That's beautiful.
>> Yeah. I don't see anything. Why would
you be blacklisted? Why would you be
kicked out of church for literally doing
something biblical?
You're not sacrificing a lamb or
anything. You're not you're also not
saying I believe that everyone has to do
this or they're not saved. You know,
it's kind of weird.
>> It is for sure. And then there's not all
that confusion because even if
Christians keep um holidays like Easter
or Christmas, there's so much added into
it that has nothing to do with the Bible
where like these every single aspect of
these feasts has a symbology that your
children can learn from.
Like that's literally why I started
looking at it and researching it cuz I'm
like I don't I don't want to confuse my
children anymore.
>> So that's what started all this. So
>> what did the Easter Bunny have to do
with Jesus again? Mommy like
>> Yeah. Um he laid eggs. That doesn't make
any sense. I don't know. [laughter]
>> Okay. So this is my favorite part. Most
scholars who have studied the feasts
will say that Jesus has fulfilled the
spring feasts. But then yeah, most
people will say, "Okay, Jesus fulfilled
the feasts. We no longer need to look at
them. We don't need to keep them.
Nothing." Um, but the interesting thing
is
when you read the Bible, we see that
Jesus fulfilled the spring feasts. And
there's a good number of scholars that
say this, but I think the majority will
say like he just fulfilled them like end
of story. But when we look at the fall
feasts, these have yet to be fulfilled
because there's no major significance
that we've had throughout history to
fall on them. And so the feast of
trumpets, uh the last three are
trumpets, atonement, and tabernacle. And
ironically, when we were looking at
sevens, all three of these feasts fall
on God's seventh month.
>> Ironically, in the Gregorian calendar,
we lose significance of months. Like our
seventh month is July, but there's is I
don't even know the name of it, but uh
it's the seventh month. I I remember
that part cuz I was like seven again.
It's seven.
>> Wow.
>> Um
>> but for us, it's like Octoberish, so it
literally is like the fall. Um but Feast
of Trumpets is super interesting because
all the other feasts have these um huge
ceremonial things and it's like do this,
do this on this day, that time. But
Feast of Trumpets is literally just
people going out and blowing the horn
the sorry the horn of chauffear. And
what it's called symbolically is a like
a wakeup call. M
>> and [clears throat] the whole point of
it is to get people ready for the day of
atonement because the day of atonement
for the um the Jewish nation was like
the most solemn, the most serious, the
most important feast because without
that they couldn't have salvation.
>> And truly like the same is true for us
like Jesus, we know Jesus is in heaven.
He is our high priest. And so without
the day of atonement, our blood or
sorry, our blood, our sins would not be
covered by his blood. And so it's still
the most important one.
>> But feast of trumpets was literally just
symbolically a divine interruption of
what they were doing. And then we see in
1 Corinthians 15:52,
it says, "In a moment, in the twinkling
of an eye, at the last trumpet, for the
last trumpet will sound and the dead
will be raised incorruptible and we
shall be changed." So, I find it really
interesting that we know Jesus is
returning at the sound of a last trumpet
and then feast of trumpets happens and
then a couple days later it's atonement
and then a couple days later it is um
tabernacle.
And so, personally, we're not, you know,
we're not time setting. I'm not going to
say it's on this date or that date or
whatever, but I think if we are to watch
the feast for uh signs of Christ's
second advent, like this to me is so
fulfilling. Like here's it could be the
last feast of trumpets and that could be
um the signal because it says he's
coming with the voice of an archangel
and the sounding of the last trumpet.
And so this could be our wakeup call.
And then we're going to look at Day of
Atonement. So, this is actually a huge
study and I know you you talk about it
sometimes, but it's super involved. But
the day that Jesus began his priestly
ministry was October 22nd, 1844. And
this was literally on the feast. So, it
was the day of atonement on 1844. And
this is why like the early um the
Millerites before the SDA church began,
they were studying. And it's like this
the the time prophecy that's in Daniel
that says there'll be so many days until
um the cleansing of the sanctuary. So
originally they thought the cleansing of
the sanctuary meant that Jesus was going
to return. He's going to cleanse the
earth. Like we're all going home.
>> Yeah. And that was the great
disappointment because that's what they
were waiting for. But after the great
disappointment happened like a ton of
the people just walked away and they're
like all right we're done with this.
Like we're done studying. But there was
a group of faithful people who were
like, "Okay,
>> it didn't happen the way we thought." So
the Bible's not wrong. We must have the
wrong interpretation of what it was
trying to say,
>> right?
>> Which is like always the right answer.
Like God's not a liar.
>> That's right.
>> Every man will be proven a liar. But
God, no.
>> Anyway, um so they went back and they
studied the prophecy over and over
again. And then as a group they realized
that was the day that Jesus went into
the heavenly sanctuary just as our high
priest because it's we're told in the
Bible he is our high priest and he
intercedes for us. And so that's the day
that the day of atonement began. Um but
we know in the Bible it says that the
day of atonement or that um the
cleansing of the sanctuary judgment
starts with God's people first.
>> Yeah. And so, like, this isn't something
that God's just going to take one day
and spend. You know, he he's meticulous
and he wants us to know at the end of
time that that he looked at every single
detail of everybody's life. He's not
just going to be like, "Yeah, I already
know about that guy." He literally looks
at the book and studies the book and to
the point where we someday will get to
look at these books and be like, "You're
right. You're right." Like, there's a
reason this person wasn't there.
>> Yeah. But um yeah, so the things that we
can learn from this is that obviously
the high priest was the mediator in the
holy temple. So only the high priest
could go behind that veil and they
sprinkled the blood of the sacrifice on
um the altar seven times for the
perfection. And now we know that Jesus
is our mediator, right? And so we can
come to Jesus and Jesus goes to God for
us. But I think we also need to remember
that we shouldn't do this casually.
>> Yeah.
>> Like some people are thinking, you know,
I'm broken. I'm sinful. I can come to
Christ. And like I knew as a baby
Christian, I kind of had this mentality
of like, oh, if I sin, I can just ask
for forgiveness.
>> Like, yeah, that's true. But if you're
planning on sinning and knowing that
you're going to be forgiven, like you've
you're you're taking Jesus's sacrifice
and you're making a mockery of it.
>> No. That's like a premeditated crime.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. So, it's like we need
to make sure that we're not approaching
the sacrifice that Jesus made for us
casually. And again, like this is lost
on us today because we have no idea what
the day the day of atonement was really
like. So, for them, this was a day that
they were fasting and they were like
literally at the temple every day
praying. I'm not every day, all day
long. They were afflicting their soul,
humbling themselves, seizing from work.
And this was their time to learn a
posture of surrender. And then we're
told in the spirit of prophecy that
those who will not participate in
afflicting our souls during the end of
time will be cut off
>> from salvation. But like literally that
mimics the day of atonement because
those who did not participate in
afflicting their soul were cut off from
the people in Leviticus 23:29.
So it's just a beautiful picture of what
we still need to be doing. And this is
supposed to be the preparation before
glory.
Okay. So, feast of trumpets
is again like blowing the horn, getting
us prepared. Day of atonement, we are
afflicting our souls and crying out for
salvation, crying for him to mediate our
sins. And then, um, oh, the last thing
was there is a pastor named David Gates,
and I highly respect him. um he was
definitely on the blacklist. So that's
one of the reasons I really like him.
>> But he speaks a lot of truth and his
idea and again I don't know if it's
true. It's just his idea is that he
thinks uh the day of atonement is when
Jesus starts his priestly ministry and
he also thinks that it will end on the
day of atonement
>> because he so believes that it's going
to fall on feast dates.
>> And so this is the best part like I
think this feast gets me the most
excited. Feast of tabernacles. So the
word tabernacle literally means God
dwelling with us. And the thing about it
is it happened at the end of the harvest
season. So this is like their
celebration of all that had God had
done. But when we look at the feast of
tabernacles as a fulfillment for
Christ's second return, we see so
Revelation 14:15. I'm actually going to
open to that. It's the end of the
harvest season, right? So, Revelation
14:15
15:15.
What it says is, "Another angel came out
of the temple crying with a loud voice
to him who sat on the cloud, thrust in
your sickle and reap, for the time has
come for you to reap, for the harvest of
the earth is ripe." So, he sat on the
cloud, thrust in a sickle of the earth,
and the earth was reaped. So again we we
it's like the symbology
the end of the season harvest like what
more would point to that than the return
of Jesus right that is when the whole
earth is going to be harvests. M
>> wow.
>> And uh okay, so the other things that we
see with the feast of tabernacle
for the um the Jewish people and well
the Israelites at that point leaving
Egypt, this represented the time that
they spent in tents when the Lord was
leading them through the desert with the
the cloud by day and the fire by night.
But the whole point of him leading them
was he was trying to take them to the
promised land. Right.
>> Mhm. And so, Feast of Tabernacles, this
is not my original thought. This is
something that came from David Gates as
well. I'm going to get to at the last
bolded point. Um, but it reminds us that
we are sojourners on the earth cuz what
they do is they make this booth. It's
also called feast of or the like feast
of booths or tabernacle. And what they
do is they make this um huge booth and
they decorate it and they fill it with
fruits. And for that seven days, they
they stay in the booth to remind
themselves of when they were living in
the tents throughout um the desert time,
which just helps us remember like this
place is not our home. It's temporary.
>> So the whole idea of the tent was they
could pick it up and go as soon as God
told them to go.
>> Oh, cool.
>> Um so yeah, when we look at um
atonement, that was the cleansing of the
earth. And then tabernacles is supposed
to be the celebration at the end of the
harvest. And this feast specifically was
called the most joyous feast. I kind of
skip over that point, but it wasn't
supposed to be like all the other ones
were kind of a time to humble yourself,
to look back on what God did, but this
is like the huge celebration of like
look what God has done. And so again,
like it just fits so perfectly with the
return of Christ because we will be so
filled with joy, like rapturous beyond
understanding. Like we can't even
comprehend what that's going to feel
like to actually
>> finally reach that day as saints. It'll
be amazing.
>> That is going to be amazing.
>> Yeah. And then, okay, so I'm I'm like
talking so fast because this excites me
so much. But the last, so the feast of
tabernacles lasts for seven days and
then it's followed by an 8th day feast.
And so this is the thought that's not
original for me. This is a David Gates
again, but Revelation 81. I'm going to
go to this and I have one more slide
that I created just to kind of look at
it a little more.
I skipped over it. 8
81. Okay. So, it says
when he opened the seventh seal again,
there's that seven. There was silence in
heaven for about a half an hour. And I
saw the angels, the seven angels who
stand before God. And they were given
seven trumpets. And so, like this is
right before the next thing starts. And
the seventh seal is when um again, all
the angels are getting ready to blow,
right? So, but here's the crazy thing.
If we look at trumpets as the time when
the last trumpet is blown and that's a
day for us to like get ready, he's
coming and then um we have the day of
atonement ending. So like God finishes
his work and then we see in Daniel it
says as soon as the time of trouble
comes that's when Michael the archangel
stands up and that means judgment is
finished in heaven. Because what you
have there in Daniel is um that God and
Jesus are in court together. When
Michael the Archangel stands up, what we
see is that judgment has been finished
because standing up means that it's
done. And so right here we have silence
in heaven for a half an hour. So I'm
just going to change
the slide here to look at this. So
again, this occurs at the seventh seal
when there's um the half hour of
silence, the prophetic understanding of
time. So numbers 14:34 and Ezekiel 4.
This shows that when we are looking at
prophecy specifically like we know that
a day um
sorry a what the thousand year look we
look at the cosmic time. So it says that
a thousand years on earth is like a day
in heaven. And so God shows us, you
know, that our earth is spanned
by thousands of years compared to
heaven. Like time goes slow here, but it
goes really fast in heaven. Like he
looks at this as just a week. Like it's
just a week and then it's all over. So
that's like when Jesus says, "I'm coming
soon." Like literally it's two days
later he's coming. Because from heaven's
perspective, it's super short. But when
we actually look at prophecy, we have to
use the Bible to interpret the Bible.
And this is something that is lost on a
lot of people. But we're going to look
at Numbers.
Actually, I don't know if you could look
that up faster than I could find it.
Numbers 14
uh 34. Okay, I did find it. So it says
according to the number of the days in
which you spied out the land 40 days for
each day you shall bear your guilt one
year namely 40 years you shall know my
rejection. And so this is the period
where God started meeting out
um one year for each day. And so it this
only occurs like in prophecy. So when
God when when God or whoever is giving
um the angel sometimes gives the message
to like Daniel, but when he says there's
um that's why I have Daniel 9 up here.
When he says there's 70 weeks, that
actually equals 490 days. But when we
see how the um prophecy was fulfilled,
it was 490 years.
>> So we don't have to guess like this is
how God works. He actually reveals this
to us. But then he also says it in
scripture. So 490 years shows us that
that day for a year method is used. And
Ezekiel says it really good, too. Would
you want to look up that one for me?
>> Ezekiel what? Um four, five, and six.
>> Four.
>> Five and six. Yes.
>> E.
So, uh, wish I could put it on screen,
but it says, "For I have laid upon thee
the years of their iniquity, according
to the numbers of the days, 390 days, so
shalt thou bear the iniquity of the
house of Israel. And when thou hast
accomplished them, lie again on thy
right side, and thou shalt bear the
iniquity of the house of Judah 40 days.
I have appointed thee each day for a
year.
>> Perfect. So yeah, these are two
different examples of where he gives
them days but then shows them these days
actually equal a year. And so because of
that, we get this this timeline that in
anytime something prophetic is shown,
it's a day for a year. So if we take
this concept and we look at that half
hour of silence in heaven, I'm not a
mathematician again, but somebody did
the math and they were like, "Okay, if a
day equals a year, how much would a half
hour equal?"
>> And you can do the math. Those of you
that are watching, you can do it on on
your own. [laughter] But what it equals
is 7 days
perfectly. 7 days. So there's a half
hour of silence in heaven which equals
seven days here on earth. And so from
the time that the trumpet is blown, we
know that that is to prepare the God's
people for his return, right? And so my
understanding of this, and I could be
wrong. I'm just going to lay this out
from what I've been studying and and
what I've seen. If people listening have
something else to say about it, like
please tell us in the comments. I love
to grow. I love to learn. But my
understanding is like feast of trumpets
is when um that last trumpet is going to
be blown and then what we see because
it's at the seventh seal, right? So it's
not like the seventh trumpets, the seven
trumpets in in revelation. It's more
like the feast of trumpets is our own
understanding to wake up and then we
have the day of atonement. And then what
we have is this half hour of silence in
heaven. And what this prefaces is the
seven trumpets that are coming. And so
the seventh trumpets that are coming
occur right after the half hour of
silence in heaven. And this is
interesting because when we look at
early writings by the spirit of
prophecy, it says we all entered the
cloud together and we were seven days
ascending to the sea of glass. M.
>> So, literally what she says is the time
it takes for us to get from earth to
heaven is 7 days, which equals the half
hour of silence in heaven. And like I
think I think I've heard Doug Bachelor
say this before, like the half hour of
silence is because Jesus has left heaven
and all of the angels have come with
him. Like it's silent because there's
literally nobody left in heaven.
Um, and when we look back, Revelation
2:3 says, "Behold, the tabernacle of God
is with men." That occurs right at the
end of of Revelation. And what we see
from the feast of tabernacles as that it
lasts seven days, like perfectly in sync
with that half hour of silence when we
know that it will take seven days to get
to heaven. And if you think about the
feast of tabernacles as being like a
symbolic fulfillment of tabernacles,
what that means is for seven days, just
as the Israelites were following Jesus
around as they were being led to the
promised land, we will be like literally
flying through the cosmos for seven days
following Jesus getting to the ultimate
promised land. And then the beautiful
part is it's followed on the eighth day
by a feast. And this is like the
greatest feast of the year. But we know
when we get back to heaven with Jesus,
that's the marriage supper of the lamb.
So that's going to like literally be the
greatest feast we've ever known. Like
tell me this doesn't fit so perfectly.
You know,
>> it does.
>> It's beautiful. It's so beautiful. Like
and again, the fact that tabernacle
means God dwelling with us. So again,
like these are just things that I'm
looking at because we're studying the
feasts. I can't tell you for sure it's
going to happen this way. God knows and
and legitimately prophecy is best
understood backwards. So when we're in
heaven, we'll have the full picture when
perfect has arrived. Like we'll be like,
"Oh, I was way off on that point." And
there'll be things that are just
mindblowing to us. But for me, like this
this to me is so beautiful of what could
be.
Um, so yeah, I'm just going to move to I
just wanted to bring this up at the end
because we talked about this um on part
one, but it says in Daniel 7:25 that he
shall speak pompous words. This is
talking about the Antichrist against the
most high. He shall persecute the saints
of the most high and shall intend to
change times and law. for the saints
will be given into his hand for time,
times, and half a time. But what I think
is significant about this is the fact
that if the Antichrist is going to
change the law, which we know he did,
right? He's he's been changing the law.
He's been telling churches and they've
been just eating it up. The fact that
>> Jesus died, we no longer need to keep
the Ten Commandments. Like, that's huge
when we look through. So, I included
Revelation 12:17, 14:12, and 22:14.
Um, you want to pick those because I
think we should actually read these.
I'll do 12:17.
>> Okay.
>> But what we see all throughout
Revelation,
>> so Revelation 14,
>> Revelation 14:12. Yeah. Yeah. All right.
Thank you.
>> But what we see is that all throughout
Revelation
there is this warning and like looking
so 12:17. I'm trying to like look it up
and talk at the same time, but it says,
"The dragon was enraged with the woman
and he went to make war with the rest of
her offspring who keep the commandments
of God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ." So, I've heard people say like,
"Oh, the Sabbath the Sabbath isn't that
important."
>> They never talk about it in Revelation.
I'm like, "Okay, but what the Bible
talks about in Revelation over and over
again is that the saints will be
following the commandments of God."
>> Yep. Because Revelation
14:12 says, "Here is the patience of the
saints. Here are they that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus."
>> Amen. Amen. So clearly all of the
commandments are important. And that's
why the enemy is so keen [clears throat]
on trying to get us to forget them.
22:14
>> and I'm going to turn to 22
224 says, "Blessed are those who do his
commandments that they may have the
right to the tree of life and may enter
through the gates into the city, but
outside are the dogs and sorcerers, the
sexually immoral and murderers and
idolattors and whoever loves and
practices a lie." Oh, that was 14 and
15. But anyway, what we see again is
that the saints, God's people, literally
have to be keeping the commandments.
This isn't legalism. This is literally
just doing what God tells us to do, what
Jesus tells us to do. And so, it's clear
why the enemy has been changing the law
because that's what allows us to be
God's children, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> So, no wonder the commandments are under
the attack constantly. Well, what I find
interesting here too is that times are
so important as well. Like why why would
the enemy care about changing God's
calendar? Why would he care about
changing God's time if it wasn't
significant for us?
>> Definitely.
>> And so like we we know that the God's
calendar has changed one because like
the calendar that we have now is
Gregorian, right? Before that, it was a
Julian calendar. And both of those
changes were made by the Roman Empire,
which is like the last beast on Daniel's
statue. So, [laughter]
>> it's like the Antichrist power that
>> Peter said, Yeah. that Peter said was
there then and now.
>> So,
even though the calendar has changed
like from today, if we were So, this is
this is something that's kind of a
hang-up for some people. Like I know a
few feast keepers and and they try to
keep the feasts like to a tea on God's
calendar. But here's a caveat. This is
interesting because if you actually look
at the Bible and what the Bible says
about God's calendar, it's not a set
fixed time. So you can't say like, okay,
every year God's new year starts on like
April 3rd. What the Bible says is that
you have to track the barley harvest.
And so you in in Jerusalem specifically,
so it says when the barley harvest is
ripe and you have the sighting of the
first new moon, that's when God's new
year is starting. So some people if
they're say like, "Oh, Jesus is going to
return like 2021
um on Passover and that's April 7th." We
literally can't do that biblically
because we won't know when Passover is
until that new year hits. And we h we
can't just assume it's going to be a
certain day. We're literally dependent
on God
every year to see what um days the
feasts fall on.
>> And when it says,
>> you said when the sprouts come up,
right? Or something like that.
>> Yeah. The it's the barley harvest. When
the barley harvest ripens.
>> Yeah. And so that's
>> God like that depends on how much rain
he sends.
>> It can change drastically from year to
year. I mean, literally it's it's
usually like a couple of weeks
difference, but it's weather dependent.
And so, um, yeah. Yeah. So, people are
like, you know, you can't know the day
and the hour that Jesus will return. And
like, for sure, we don't know the day
and the hour because the calendar has
been so skewed. Like, even if I'm like,
okay, I think it's going to be on the
day of tabernacle. That's when he's
going to come. Like, do I really
understand how to find the day of
tabernacle? No, I don't. And like I can
I can search it biblically out. And so
like this year we tried to figure out,
okay, biblically what is the first day
of the year? And there are literally
hundreds of perspectives on the
internet. They're like, "Oh, according
to the barley harvest and the the first
new moon over Jerusalem, it should be
this day." But then all these other
feast keepers are following a different
day. So it's just like I don't know.
It's confusing,
>> right? But what we what I think is
interesting is like he's really specific
and he says that nobody will know the
day or the hour. But I'm I'm going to be
bold and say does that mean we don't
know the year?
>> Could we possibly know the season?
>> Because it doesn't say month. It doesn't
say year. You know, we could know that
if we're really watching and really
studying God's word, but again, I think
it's all going to God's people will
know. We're going to be studying. We're
going to be learning. and those signs
are going to be there. Everything is
going to unfold.
Um, so here's my last thought.
You guys talk about this a lot and I'm
super thankful for it because there's
not a lot of
>> channels that literally will speak
truth, but we know in Revelation 18:4,
and I'm sure you can talk about this
longer than I could, but he calls he he
tells the world, "Come out of her, my
people." And so Mikey like what is he
talking about with this
>> come out of her is the the churches that
are the daughters of the harlots of the
harlot. So there's a harlot church that
is literally the Vatican that sits on
the city of seven hills. That's what the
seven heads represent. Seven hills or
mountains. The church that's decked in
gold and precious stones and purple and
scarlet and all that is the Vatican. But
there's
many, many, many other churches out
there that are
um drunk on the wine of her fornication,
which is false doctrine. So the doctrine
of what happens when you die, that you
actually, you know, you never really
die. You float out of your body and you
go somewhere, heaven or hell for
eternity. Or the idea that hell is a
eternal torment, that people are
tormented endlessly in the fiery pits of
hell is not biblical or Sunday
sacredness, which those three um beliefs
alone cover so many churches. And when
you come to the truth of what does the
word of God say, not the traditions of
man, not what my church says or my
pastor even,
>> um God's saying, "Heed the truth and
come out of her lest you taste of the
plagues and her being a representation
of
the the churches that are the daughters
of the harlot that are drunk on the wine
of her false doctrine."
>> 100%. Yeah, I know you'd say that better
than I would.
>> So, but yeah, like it's literally the
call. So, it and and you did it well in
in saying that it's the Vatican and like
all of their beliefs, but in in
Revelation specifically, it says
Babylon, right? So, come out of Babylon.
>> And you and your wife do a really great
job of showing how Babylon is still very
present today.
>> Yeah. Ironically though, the fact that
it's the Vatican, like the Vatican is
what's pushing this um this false
religion that the world is following.
Again, like that's the Roman system.
That's the same system that set up these
false calendars that now we're, you
know, holding Easter and Christmas and
Valentine's Day and all these holidays
that mean nothing biblically.
>> Yeah.
>> But yet we're following them and we
don't like we don't even know why.
Truthfully, you ask Christians why, and
they're like, "I don't I don't know."
>> But, um,
>> I think one aspect that we really need
to consider is that [snorts]
>> this is part of the three angels
message. And so, they're saying, "Come
out of Babylon." And I think for God's
people, we so quickly turn our eyes to
those that we know are doing it wrong.
And we're like, "Right, we got to tell
them to come out of Babylon. We got to
tell them what they're doing wrong." But
I think before we can ever look
outwardly, right, we got to get that
before we look at the speck in our
brother's eyes, we got to get the plank
out of our own. And so I think this is a
huge call to us saying first, we have to
get Babylon out of our own hearts. Like
in all ways, like God, what am I doing
that's not truly of the Bible? What do I
need to let go of that I've been holding
on to that's just a tradition that's
empty? And I think after we do that,
then we really have the ability to draw
people to the truth and the purity of
God and his word.
>> Amen.
>> So that's just just an encouragement for
us to really consider, you know, what it
is that we need to work on ourselves.
And I'm in that same boat. Like I know
that there's things that God is really
showing me like that's that's worthless.
That's pointless. Stop doing that.
>> Yeah.
>> And then this is just one last quote.
Um, again this is from the spirit of
prophecy and it says we have many
lessons to learn and many many to
unlearn and this is so big for me. God
and heaven alone are infallible. Those
who think they will never have to give
up a cherished few will be disappointed.
>> And so I think it's just so relevant for
us today. Yeah. It's just so good
because we have so many things in our
lives that are cherished. traditions of
our family or culture or you know just
things that we've learned from the
church and again we don't know why but
we need to always be looking to God and
be like God what do you want me to do in
these end times and like again we see
that the 144,000 those of God will be
following Jesus. They know his voice.
They listen to him and they're following
wherever he goes.
>> Amen.
>> And I think that that means like we're
going to be in places we're not
expecting to be. And sometimes that
place is just alone. You're like, you're
not going to have a whole church backing
you up in what you're standing for.
Sometimes God calls us to stand on
things that aren't popular.
>> That's so true.
>> So, yeah, I'm just hoping that this
presentation will inspire people more
than anything to study the feasts more
and to realize that there's huge
relevance in them.
>> Yeah, I know. I haven't done that and
this has been really eye opening, really
cool to see. Yeah. what the significance
of these things, they're important.
There wasn't it wasn't just because God
said, you know what, I think this would
be, you know, interesting or fun or
whatever. There's a there's a real
reason behind why people did what they
were or why God told them to do things a
certain way. And um man, it's just
really cool to see like you were talking
about the feast of trumpets could be
that's what you're talking about, right?
That Christ could return on the feast of
trumpets, right?
Yeah. I mean, it could be it could be
the feast of trumpets. It could be like
on I don't see what I think it could be
is like the feast of trumpets is are
like our time to get ready because he'd
have to finish the day of atonement and
that would be in heaven. Then that comes
after trumpets. And then I think it's uh
tabernacles because that's the the half
hour of silence in heaven. And then
that's a seven day of traveling through
the cosmos and then following with the
marriage supper of the lamb.
>> So something in my brain is like is is
just focusing on the tabernacles. I
don't know.
>> Yeah.
>> I really don't know.
>> We'll see. I'll tell you what I won't be
doing is I won't be just like sitting
around in a lawn chair on feast of
trumpets and [laughter] atonement being
like, "Oh, what's going to happen?" Like
I'm going to be on my knees praying
like, "God,
>> it could be today. It could be in a
week. could be 10 days for tabernacle,
but like get me prepared. Get my family
prepared. I'm going to be pouring my
heart out to the Lord and not
>> that is Yeah, that's my prayer every day
when me and my wife pray together just
to we're praying for our lost family.
We're praying for us ourselves, too.
Like, Amen.
>> I want to be sure that I'm ready. I
don't want to miss out. I don't want to
get deceived. You know, my biggest fear
is
even more than uh persecution. The pain
of torment or any of those things that
is temporal and you can just tough it
out, grin and bear it until it's over.
But deception, the deception that is
coming is going to be so great that if
you don't understand what the word of
God says, you will fall for it. It's
going to play on your emotions. It's
going to play on your senses. You're
seeing signs and wonders and miracles.
And if we don't understand what's
coming, we will be deceived. And so, I'm
constantly praying for God to give us
spiritual eyes, to give us discernment,
to help us understand what's going on.
Because, man, this world is so
deceiving. I I see how Satan plays both
sides and how people are choosing. Oh,
no. I'm a conservative Republican or I'm
I'm this, I'm that, and I side with
Charlie Kirk or Trump or whoever. It's
like
either way we're deceived because we're
we're not supposed to be siding with the
ideas of this world. We're supposed to
be
studying prophecy and understanding
what's soon to come. And um
>> for sure.
>> Yeah. I've just been praying a lot about
being ready
because,
you know, we we we know ourselves. We
know that we're not faultless and we
know we're not perfect. And
yeah, I just been praying it a lot.
[snorts]
>> Amen. Amen. My husband and I, we
actually talk a lot about how
when like times get nitty-gritty and you
really see stuff's happening, we're
like, we're just going to be breaking
our phones. Like literally all of our
technology is going to be gone because
because of the deception. Like we can
barely tell the truth between AI now,
but
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. I think there's just going to be
so much on technology that's going to be
deceiving the world. So I'm like it says
don't even look, right? Like if they say
he's in the desert or in the in a room,
don't even look. But if we have our
phones, we're going we're going to look
and we're going to see. So it's like I'm
just scrolling on the wall. Oh, there it
was. You know,
>> whoa, that's interesting,
>> right? Like I mean we're already like
that. Sometimes you're like you don't
even realize why you're scrolling and
something catches your eye. you're just
watching it and you're like, "Why am I
watching this?"
>> Right. Exactly.
>> But I mean, there's a reason. There's a
reason why they like legitimately
research how to make all of it
addicting. Like, technology is addicting
to the point where the people who invent
it don't even let their families use it.
>> That's right.
>> Like, come on. And if you think about
things from the enemy's perspective,
they're doing it for money. Like, the
creators of Facebook, the creators of
Tik Tok, all that, they're just out
there for money.
for sure. But like Satan is using them
to make technology so addicting to reach
the generations to reach people. And
like you're saying, I think he's going
to use it in a huge way for deception in
the end.
>> But yeah, we're all going to have to do
some uh some cutting out in the end. And
I did want to bring up, so Mikey, you
had shared this with me. I hope you
don't mind me um sharing on live, but
you had a guy contact you from Yeah. cut
me off if not,
>> but uh he shared from Spain that he's
been studying the cosmic week.
>> Yeah.
>> And um I started watching some of his
videos and they're really good, but he
had mentioned that he believes Jesus is
coming back on 2031.
>> Mhm.
>> And I had previously said that I was
thinking it was 2030. And this is why if
you research just online and you ask
what year was Jesus crucified, they'll
it'll say either 2030 or 203 or sorry,
not 2033,
AD30
or AD33.
And so that's why we add 2,000 to that.
And so um
I just I I was assuming it was 2030
because of 30 AD
>> and because there's no zero year
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. A lot of people forget that the
zero and you got to like calculate that
in,
>> right?
>> But it's it's based off of um 8030 and
8033 as the most um
I guess popular choices for choosing the
day of his crucifixion. It's based on um
the historical timeline of like Pontius
Pilate and um the day that the feasts
land on in history.
So, it's really interesting. But I'm
going to go back and finish watching
some of his videos because again, like I
I've been saying 2030 because I thought
that Jesus was crucified on 30 AD. So,
you add, you know, 2,000 years to that.
But the big picture is, okay, let's say
that it's 2030, 2031, 2033. Like, that
is nothing. That's a drop in the hat,
>> dude. 5 years gone by like I cannot
believe I I've been thinking about some
things that happened in my life. I was
like
>> that's 5 years ago. It feels like two.
It's crazy.
>> I know.
>> It goes by so fast. I mean
>> if if we were told by God himself like
Jesus is coming back in 5 years, you
better get ready. Like
>> it goes by so fast time
>> for us to wake up.
>> Yeah. I mean think about all the
I'm just think we we've talked about
some of this stuff before like the end
is coming. What do you need to do to
prepare and all this stuff and like I
mean if we're really going to be
prepared for overcoming the mark of the
beast and stuff, you you need to be
living off grid, you need power without
being in the in the grid. You need water
that's a well, natural water somewhere.
you need to be growing your own food
because I I believe 100% that there is
about to be an economy collapse
purposefully a manufactured
second great depression that's going to
>> for sure
>> yeah between AI taking over so many jobs
and Trump going up on tariffs all that
stuff is orchestrated this is exactly
what happened in the first uh great
depression was high tariffs and jobs
being laid off. Um the next thing to
come is panic and not enough food on the
shelves and you know they're already
there's already um strikes with truck
drivers and stuff like
>> we are just like the days of Noah right
now eating, drinking, giving in marriage
like living like days are just normal
but they're really not. There's bad
times right around the corner and I
think so many of us so many of us are
not even ready. And I'm even talking to
myself. We're trying. We have a garden
out there, but right now there's nothing
to eat. I'll just say that. Yeah. And
>> yeah,
super important. You know, I think one
thing that helps my husband and I is cuz
when you talk about like preparing and
things like that, at least for me, my
anxiety starts to like
so much to do.
>> But I think more than anything, it's a
spiritual preparedness that we need to
focus on.
>> Definitely. I do think there's prepping
involved.
>> Yeah. But if you are spiritually in tune
to the Lord, he's going to lead you.
Like the spirit of prophecy actually
says that in the end people, the saints
will be living in groups of like-minded
and we'll be taking care of each other.
>> And so I believe even now like I know
some people that are having um
preparations made on these huge plots of
land and like they're literally waiting.
They're like I know Jesus is going to
send people to us.
>> Wow. So I'm like, "Oh, sign me up."
Like,
>> "Yeah, [laughter] come get on the
waiting list."
>> Yeah.
>> Um, so I think I mean I think we do the
best that we can, but but God is also
preparing people who are preparing for
others.
And like that's what we see like Elijah,
he didn't have um food or water, but God
prepared brought it to him when he
needed it.
>> Yeah. And so if we're if we're the Lord
and we're doing all that we can to, you
know, repent and stay true to what God
is telling us to do, he's not just going
to leave us hanging.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh he's going to prepare.
>> I mean, otherwise just sign me up for
the G the guillotine. I don't
>> I was going to say, [laughter] you know,
Shadow, Meshach, and Abednego, even if
he doesn't save us through the fiery
furnace, we won't bow down. Like there's
nothing this world has to offer that is
better than eternal life in a perfect
world with Jesus. There just isn't.
>> Amen.
>> All the torture in the world,
starvation, whatever, it's not going to
I'm not going to conform to the mark of
the beast system just to survive in this
world a little while longer and miss out
on eternity. It's not worth it.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Well, thank you so I hope that wasn't
like some kind of like dreadful ending
like this is exciting. Yeah, I'm I'm so
glad that you came and brought this
information because I think the point of
it is to wake up the sleeping virgins.
You know, the Jesus told a parable about
>> virgins that all fell asleep. The
virgins represent the Christians in the
church,
>> and they all fell asleep, but
>> when they woke up, five were ready and
five weren't. They were some had enough
oil to get to the wedding, the others
didn't. And we do not want to be those
five foolish virgins. We want to be
ready. We want to be watchful. And it's
exciting. Um it can be scary, but we're
not supposed to live in fear. We're not
supposed to,
>> right?
>> Uh we're supposed to be excited and and
be be getting ready. And I am. I pray
literally every day. I'm just like,
"Lord, please come." You know, and then
I remember
>> my family and friends that aren't ready.
maybe I'm not ready or whatever. We know
that Jesus is long-suffering. He's not
willing that any should perish. That's
the only thing that's holding him back.
He wants as many people to come with
him. And actually, the more he carries
um the the worse the world gets, the
more people will surrender because
they're going to they're going to find
out, wait a minute, all those crazy
Christians were right. It's coming true.
like I need to
>> I need to surrender my life, you know.
>> So, it's really merciful that God is
allowing all these bad things to happen
>> because it pushes us closer to him.
>> For sure. And yeah, you know, the Bible
says that we are not given that God does
not give us a spirit of fear, but of
power and love and a sound mind.
>> Amen.
>> And so, we don't have to have that fear.
Like, that is the enemy's tactic is to
get us afraid of what's to come,
>> right? But really, we got to look at the
end of it. It's like it's like birth
pains, right? If any woman has ever had
a baby before. I literally have PTSD. We
thought about having a third child, and
I'm like, "Oh, I don't know how I can't
do it."
>> I just think about that birth. I'm like,
that birth was so hard. Like, you're
going to have to go through hard times,
but after you have that baby, you know,
after Jesus comes, it's like none of it
will matter.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't remember who said it, but it
might have been like part of Schindler's
List or something. It was some some like
quote from a movie and
I I know it was based on a true story,
but the guy kept running back into like
dangerous territory to rescue people and
>> um Hacksaw Ridge.
>> Was it Hacksaw Ridge?
>> Yeah, it does.
>> I mean, I know I know that story. Yeah,
but it's some quote. I almost feel like
it's a Schindler's List or something,
but that's really similar.
>> Yeah. But what he's what he's um I think
it's like rescuing children from like
Nazi trains or something.
>> It's like this amazing story. I'll have
to find share with you sometime. But his
quote was like everyone kept telling
him, "You've done so much. You can
stop." And he's like, "Just one more.
Just one more. If I can rescue just one
more."
>> Yeah.
>> And like literally that's going to be
our only regret when we get to heaven.
We're not going to care about the
vacations we didn't have, the places we
didn't see,
>> the accomplishments, nothing. hours did
I spend on Fortnite?
>> Yeah, certainly not. But yeah, like
we're going to regret when that when
that fire comes down and all the people
who missed out on God, we're going to
regret that we didn't do more to try to
reach them. Like it's it's weird because
the Bible says that it's like a a
strange act when God destroys the people
with fire.
>> Yeah. But I think like literally Jesus
will be weeping and we will be it's
going to be the most sorrowful moment of
all existence. But then he wipes the
tears from our eyes.
>> Amen.
>> And then you know the new Jerusalem
we're there and from that point on
there's no more tears, no more crying.
All of it's done forever. Death is done
forever.
>> So beautiful to look forward to.
>> Amen.
>> We're gonna have to get through some bad
stuff but
>> there's a beautiful ending. It'll all be
worth it. And we'll we'll be singing a
song that nobody else will know how to
sing because we survived through that.
It's going to be awesome.
>> Amen.
>> Well, thank you so much for coming on
and bringing this. I know a lot of
people were excited to hear part two
because it dropped off. This was really
uh very educational. I I didn't know a
lot of this stuff and it's really
exciting that there's still things in
the Bible that we can learn. It's not a
book that you ever finish. It's the
living word of God. We're going to be
studying this thing for all eternity and
we're going to get to be like with Jesus
and say, "Can you imagine asking Jesus,
what does this mean? Please explain this
because I heard so many different
things." And he's going to be like, "Oh,
let me tell you. It's going to be
awesome." [laughter] But yeah, thank you
for bringing this. It was really
inspiring, encouraging, and educational.
I think a lot of people are going to be
blessed by it. So, thank you so much. I
look forward to having you back on for
something else. You got a lot of cool
stuff to talk about and share.
Yeah, for sure. I love your channel. So,
I'm happy to help out in any way I can.
>> And you do help out. She does a lot of
our social media stuff. So, for people
that didn't know, behind the scenes.
>> Tiny bit.
>> Oh, you do.
>> Just a tiny bit. [laughter]
>> You do awesome. Well, thank you so much.
I'm going to sign us off here.
Thank you guys so much for being with us
tonight. If you enjoyed this, if you
were blessed, if you learned something,
please give this video a thumbs up. It
really helps this video get out into the
algorithm so more people can see it. If
you're new to this channel, click the
subscribe button and the notification
bell so you won't miss another episode.
And if you'd like to support this
ministry, you can do so by going to
canidtruth.org. We got Cash App,
Vinmozelle, PayPal. We even have
Patreon, and we have cool merchandise.
If you'd like to get a shirt that says,
"Be cool, use your brain, the truth will
set you free, love is kind, and many,
many more." We get about $5 per sale on
that, and it really helps to keep this
ministry alive and going. And if you are
giving, we see you. We love you. We
cannot do this without you. We want to
say thank you so much for your love and
support. And we'll see you next time on
Can of Truth.